alright Kengo the pro part of the castle
got damnit I don't trust this
Alice Bailey I am the bigger version you
should be proud of yourself you got in
this fight I had to get I'm a but hey
I'm a bunny hey hey little bunny yeah he
doing bunny what are you two friends no
I'm just like it's a kill that bunny
pity stare into his eyes and it will not
matter yet alright fine I'm a bunny
camera bunny hammer bunny remember I
don't trust Bernie speedy alright this
time but that rat what's going on
everybody all right I don't touch it I
just keep going and pretend you don't
know what is this I got that oh hey what
the [ __ ]
alright this guy's a bunny was huge but
stalker bunny with a [ __ ]
alright hey what is this finally a
weapon
alright you picked up a wave shaped
knife this note is written in battle
ease I can't read that [ __ ] battle is
what the [ __ ] did that daughter lock
itself for just barreling that I barely
where you're going
Sarge and forgot about you I'm sorry
alright but this is place oh Jesus
Christ pity what are you doing let's go
ahead
I'm a bunny uh I display okay
oh god damn it you're screwed pity
how are you gonna get past him okay I
got a plan you might not like it but
it's a plan just surround like
[ __ ]
okay I mean it usually when the girls
are looking don't stab him with a knife
quick
all right girls to follow but I killed
the bra hahaha
yeah you backstabbing son of a [ __ ] why
would you do that
look at my nipples let's just let me
show you my nipples
get the man cleanest nipple without
getting bad stuff Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ [ __ ] I tripped on this thread
market damn it
all right oh no addition splice admit it
hello
oh god Abby picked up a key bro what's
going on are you coming I think it's
coming what are you doing to miss Chen
had a parody if that's your real name
don't mind what you're seeing just
continue walking yes after I paid
continue walking okay the shares are
officially creeping me out so I'm just
gonna pretend that I don't know what's
going on and then we can keep going
there should be a door here somewhere
maybe I'm there just stairs I didn't see
a door that wasn't locked
it's in here so dark scary but it's the
key I got the key
it must be under the stairs I think this
way pity don't don't try to think
without me just another staff I will
tell you but I just walking circles now
hear this all right III hear this all
right good all right this now let's do
this Wow
the careful pity you don't have a
lantern Oh God
this is not good just I know you're
scared of car does pity but I'm with you
all right take it really [ __ ] easy
red light it's not good light unless
you're having sex I don't think you are
right
yeah I'm not having sex okay good
continue there's a lantern god damn it
now we good holy [ __ ] I told here you
just have to be a good eye net Oh God oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] toy Isaac it out Justin
car locks oh god I pardon I dance
oh he disappeared lucky for him I would
have freaking killed him with his side
hey come out hey mister share what do
you do
I got I wasn't doing anything I was just
working out some weapons holy [ __ ] a
sword
I am Excalibur
oh holy [ __ ] I want to penetrate the bro
with it's like wow this is awesome
well you want to fire me [ __ ] what else
do we got
I freaking axe yeah alright let's chop
some wood mother bye guys oh wait what
else we got
we are now that oh man I'm in paradise
what is that this weapons are made by
stefano he said that they would say pity
from the book italia I made this I'm a
blacksmith it's obvious all right pretty
cool alright let's pick up the key you
picked up the key to the basement but I
I guess I have to choose between the
okay let's go back got that WA unuseful
yeah weapons those were awesome would be
awesome if you could use ah you can't
don't go underneath - oh oh where did
the broker item out this is not good I
thought you carry them what I got amber
Karim alright let's use the key and go
to the basement to the basement third
baseman
ah what happened ah lion that lion no no
no no no all right let's go
continue hello lick me today I told
another leg wave ah Jesus Christ I know
I'm a scholar and lickable but that
doesn't mean you can lick me sorry I got
no landing apparently thank you scholars
oh oh no oh no I hate the exploding
doors ah
I just it's beautiful
alright ask Holy Mother penis what the
[ __ ] is that
huh that's the father everywhere for you
Safari you so crazy
alright let's pick up those sand erosion
no one needs to get hurt
from the oil finally you crazy son of a
[ __ ]
what is that muck ding ah Peter I don't
like it when you scare me like that
British I'm hiding yes I know where that
you are hiding from the barrels that's
what you always do and why did you make
this mess because I can't find the
father that makes sense alright bye I I
found this key it's an old key and I
found it all right let's go payday
let's finish this out the door is locked
yeah I got the key so it's finding it
Jesus guys that's an awesome key yeah I
think
all right let's continue
we got the fun okay this way pity I
don't know why I sing sometimes it's
really weird can't make sense of it but
be careful I don't cross this place and
the burro you didn't kill them still
alive don't know if your letter
hahaha okay turning it up I'm sorry
oh you so crazy what's going on here
Oh what the [ __ ]
what's going on Jennifer
huh
with the book
Oh
gah graphs and stuff what's going on
all right that thing is gone that [ __ ]
oh no oh no pin it yours good daddy
buddy naked don't wanna make you guys
it's worse
hey televising naked guys it's kind of
sexy though yeah let's get us to Jesus
guys I'm not officer natee alright it's
going here
Jesus Christ I'm [ __ ] telling Papa
Papa is that you're sad you're that I
look I waited my entire I am why now
ah ah all right good judge me rich of
that story all right I can't talk down
but you need to go down this hallway
all right left right left and I'll try
to get how we'll ever very light all
these directions some horrible things
will happen to you and we'll meet you
there
now Joe alright fine I'll go as I have
the worst [ __ ] memory I should
actually write that them Wow
okay what's right right and then left
the huh and then left and then
[Music]
right I guess all right let's go ahead
all right go on
all right go ahead awesome all right why
don't we get I'm lost
hey what the [ __ ] alright but this place
go ahead go left
go ahead Wow I died I guess I'm going
wait right left right
god I won low house it's possible by
stefano
i got damn we lost the phone ok let's do
it again right yes laughs I guess so now
then walk left no I can't
okay right there all right and now no oh
oh yeah again it was right left
what was it [ __ ] however I'm a [ __ ]
it's obvious I can't use my landing for
some reason then left again next time
and then right I think
[Music]
all right yes left and then right again
I got this problem I'm like the only one
in the entire world who will get suck at
this part all right and then continue
and then right I hope yes yes I did it
all by myself
oh so the one will be flying Jesus
guitar god damn it I did it I forgot
about the doggy
I really hope
- Govan they want to be the first
customer
little more I still really really
appreciate all these
rosanell all the things to do for me I'm
ready for the mind alone buy all of it
anyway that end street I hope you both
enjoyed I'm real surprised that there
were so many people so many groaning
it's crazy it's crazy I mean I played
for two hours and there's still almost
7,000 people that's a spacing I was so
proud of you bros I couldn't be happier
that to have such animal awesome
subscriber base really it's it's amazing
but I'm sorry I can't record more like I
out be like I I'm sorry I hope you
understand anyway I'll definitely do
this again sometime and and as all these
thanks for supporting me and all that
kind of stuff with whatever you do I
can't thank you enough I love you all I
will end the stream new and I'll see you
with the new videos tomorrow all right I
had to end it
I'm sorry I have to end it now and sign
it all over the brofist all right you
ready you ready after wait for the delay
it's alright brofist
laughter wait forever breakfast
come on browse I'm waiting I love
pudding
alright one two three
[Music]
bunch of people would just want to put
their face right in there and just know
are you crazy
put a pea-pickin can we please go what
are you talking about
we just got him started